we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman steady md lets you maintain
a meaningful long lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started
wow uh welcome welcome to the show
everybody uh the last 24 hours
in american politics are the craziest 24
hours i've ever been involved with
with from the standpoint of of covering
them and we had
um i think six hours of live streams
yesterday in addition to the broadcast
show and the bonus show
and uh almost an impossibility to even
keep
up with what is going on so today's show
is going to be very different than any
show we've done
we are in a sense we are winging it and
what i mean by that is
um i have about 13 or 14 different
stories that i would like to talk about
today
um and we may get to all of them and we
may not in other words we
i'm starting today not with every minute
planned as we normally have uh
but with an idea of the things we should
discuss
and we'll just jump into them and i hope
i know a lot of you have been emailing
me saying i can't keep up
well we we haven't been able to keep up
either so let's try to do justice to the
last 24 hours because the historical
significance really cannot be
overstated let's start with what
happened yesterday yesterday
january 6th was meant to be the day
during which there would be a merely
ceremonial counting of the electoral
votes which were cast on december 14th
in the november election joe biden won
via popular vote in the 50 u.s states
winning some losing some getting enough
electoral votes
to become president on december 14th the
electors in all 50 states
certified their uh state's election
and on january 6th those ballots already
having been cast on december 14th
a joint session of the house and senate
led by vice president mike pence as
president of the senate was to
simply count those votes now we knew
there would be some chaos
because for two months donald trump has
been uh insisting without evidence that
he actually won
that it was rigged that he wants uh this
state to be overturned that he wants
that state to be overturned that there
were massive
dumps of ballots that mike pence needs
to do the right thing
and that something and it wasn't just
trump but many of his
most sycophantic supporters who were
hoping
planning believing that something would
happen yesterday
that would prevent joe biden from being
determined in that joint session by mike
pence
the winner of the 2020 election now i'll
skip to the end
it happened it was delayed by a few
hours but it happened and we will get to
that
but what we imagined would simply be
some debate
we knew there would be senators and
members of the house
on the republican side standing up and
objecting to the
the counting of ballots from certain
states arizona for example pennsylvania
and others we knew that would happen
we expected there would be a couple of
hours of debate for each of those
objections
but that ultimately republicans didn't
have the vote to hold up even
a single state's votes from being
counted and that it might be 10 pm it
might be 1 a.m it might be 3 a.m it
might be this morning or later today
eventually they would run out of
objections they would run out of votes
and that would be
it but something else happened
something else happened which is that in
the morning donald trump
incited an insurrectionist mob
to march down pennsylvania avenue
to the capitol building and wreak havoc
uh break down doors and destroy windows
commit property crimes fight with police
some police actually injured and this
was
fomented directly by donald trump and
this is not to say that many of these
folks didn't have this
idea going into yesterday already but i
am going to show you how donald trump
did this donald trump
literally told them what to do and later
said
oh b please be peaceful but we will get
to that here is donald trump at this
wacky event i don't know what they were
calling it it was a steal the election
rally essentially
here is trump again saying mike pence
you'd better do the right thing
the left knows exactly what they're
doing
they're ruthless and it's time that
somebody did something about it and mike
pence i hope you're going to stand up
for the good of our constitution and for
the good
of our country and if you're not i'm
going to be very disappointed in you i
will tell you right now
i'm not hearing good stories ultimately
donald trump ended up denouncing his own
vice president mike pence and we will
get to that later
donald trump continuing to fire up the
crowd by saying the caravans are forming
remember those caravans
that up until the day before the 2018
midterms
were every day in right-wing media the
caravans of dangerous hispanic
immigrants are coming
2018 midterms happen we don't hear about
the caravans ever again until yesterday
here is trump ginning up more uh uh uh
hate
by saying the caravans are forming
because they know biden will let them in
but now the caravans they think biden's
getting in the caravans are forming
again
they want to come in again and rip off
our country can't let it happen
and then here is donald trump just
literally telling them what to do saying
we're gonna march up pennsylvania avenue
we're gonna go to the capitol
he said he told them what to do and they
did it take a look
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania avenue
and we're going to the capitol and we're
going to try and give
the democrats are hopeless they're never
voting for anything
not even one vote but we're going to try
and give
our republicans the weak ones because
the strong ones don't need any of our
help
we're going to try and give them the
kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
so let's walk down pennsylvania avenue
i want to thank you all god bless you
and god
bless america thank you all for being
here this is incredible thank you very
much
thank you
[Music]
and that is exactly that is exactly what
they did
while we were covering what i thought
would just be
really boring debate for hour after hour
about republican objections to the
counting of ballots from certain states
we saw live and we saw we had over 1.1
million different people
watch at least some piece of our live
stream yesterday we all
saw with with horror most of us uh
as the angry mob of trumpists
became angrier and angrier fighting
with police eventually overwhelming law
enforcement and there are many questions
about how that happened
where where was law enforcement and
there are there's everything from
speculation to conspiracy theories to
mere belief of incompetence and at some
point we will sort that out
overwhelming law enforcement breaking
into the capital leading to mike pence
being taken out of there by by a secret
service
leading to house and senate leadership
being taken sort of in protective
custody or
you know by security to safe safe
an evacuation of the house and senate
chambers protesters and mobsters and
rioters i don't even know what to call
them
broke into nancy pelosi's office uh and
they they did they did exactly what
would be on the logical end of
two months of firing people up with lies
culminating with trump saying
at 12 30 p.m half an hour before this
all started
we're going to march over down
pennsylvania ave
to the capitol eventually after things
got completely out of control and i know
i'm not going to get
every detail right or i'm not going to
get every detail into the story
discussions about do we deploy the
national guard reports that trump
resisted but ultimately mike pence made
the decision to deploy
the national guard trump seemingly not
wanting to deploy the national guard
against his own supporters
and eventually donald trump uploaded a
video saying to people
it's time to go home he says you're
great people
we love you it was stolen it was a
landslide then we actually went
but it's time to go home and that video
was
ultimately locked by twitter later
removed
removed by facebook i didn't even find
it on youtube unclear whether they
uploaded and it was removed
it was a video uh essentially
defending the feelings and the actions
but saying it's time to go home
and repeating the exact same stuff that
jinned up the the anger
in the first place trump then also
tweeted basically a defense of the
rioters as he told them to go home
this was also removed by twitter donald
trump saying these are the things and
events that happen
when a sacred landslide election victory
is so unceremoniously and viciously
stripped away from great patriots
who have been badly and unfairly treated
for so long he is saying
this is what happens when you steal the
election from me it makes sense that
this is what's happening
and then he adds go home with love and
in peace
remember this day forever uh also
ultimately removed from twitter
trump defending the actions of the
violent writers while sort of staying
saying go home so we're going to talk
about
reaction to this and the discussion of
the removal of donald trump
we will of course cover the fact that
biden did get the votes yesterday
there are rumors that will there will be
more rioting today and very important
there were only as of now
52 arrests yesterday even though there
were clearly hundreds if not thousands
of people
who trespassed did property damage uh
attacked police broke the law in many
different ways the fbi
has said it is a priority to identify
every single person who did that
so i i'm not going to call names out
specifically on this show but there
are known right-wing activists and and
nuts
who are pictured inside the capitol and
and committing crimes trespassing etc
um let's help the fbi there should be
hundreds if not thousands of arrests
from what happened yesterday
and there have only been 52 as of five
minutes ago so
let's let's actually uh uh make justice
be done because
these are folks who deserve a criminal
record we talk about someone holding
uh you know hold holding uh a tiny
amount of cannabis
who ends up with a criminal record and
how insane that is
these are folks who deserve criminal
records okay so let's do what we can to
make that happen
all right let's now go to the v the most
important thing
that happened yesterday is something
that didn't happen and what i mean by
that is
the rioters were not able to prevent joe
biden's win from being confirmed
as i was saying yesterday as we watched
with increased horror
during these live streams almost six
seven hours of stream yesterday as we
watched
the capitol breached and the senate and
house chambers evacuated and violence
violence violence even including
uh you know a woman died yesterday a q
anon nut who believed yesterday was
going to be a day of reckoning of some
kind a sort of
pseudo-religious belief almost about
what was going to take place
horrible what we saw yesterday but their
goal was
to prevent joe biden's win from being
counted
remember states already certified on
december 14th but from being counted
and they were unable to do that and as i
said yesterday
the most important thing is safety
lock down the area secure the building
make sure nobody gets hurt as few people
as possible get hurt
but we can't allow them to actually
delay the process
and indeed very late at night early this
morning
congress certified the election of
president-elect
joe biden uh this was
you know there was almost a backfire
which we will talk about in a moment but
here is the moment where mike pence did
that
the votes for president of the united
states are as follows
joseph r biden jr of the state of
delaware has received 306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
the whole number of electors appointed
to vote for vice president of the united
states is 538. within that whole number
a majority is 270.
the votes for vice president of the
united states are as follows
kamala d harris of the state of
california has received 306 votes
michael r pence of the state of indiana
has received 232 votes
the announcement of the state of the
vote by the president of the senate
shall be deemed a sufficient declaration
of the persons elected president
and vice president of the united states
each for the term beginning on the 20th
day of january
2021 had they been able to delay this
more than a few hours
um it would send a really bad signal it
would embolden them to do this in the
future and again i want to mention
only 52 people as of right now it may be
more by the time you listen to this only
52 people have been arrested so far
uh we need to make sure everybody who
participated in this and broke the law
is arrested because otherwise they will
be emboldened to try this again
but it didn't work joe biden
everything happened no note that despite
all of this
everything happened on the day it was
supposed to happen december 14th
certifications
january 6th okay bled into the seventh
but it was expected to anyway because
remember
if there had been objections from
republicans in six different
states each generating two hours of
debate
this would have pushed into january
seventh anyway
because of the riots some republicans
opted not to object in some of those
states
so by rioting the rioters actually
sped up in a sense the process of just
counting and accepting the joe biden win
and that's really really important
now what this all means for the future
of the country we just don't know
uh there there's really no parallel to
this i mean we
you know it insurgents acting violently
in the name of trump
vandalized the capital i from what i saw
there has not been a breach of the
capital like this since
early 19th century um they
objected without any evidence uh
that they could put forward to the
acceptance of joe biden's victory
claiming vaguely that it was rigged with
conflicting and unhinged
uh hypotheses and this is essentially
the worst i mean listen okay they could
have also brought guns and started
mowing people down right like we can all
always imagine some worse scenario but
when you talk about
what is the opposite of a peaceful
transition of power
what is the worst that this could
possibly get what could be the possibly
most dire repercussions of donald
trump's
agitation it's essentially this it's
essentially this
we saw it it's disgusting people need to
be held accountable but
importantly it's over again
joe biden won again another milestone
that the trumpists were waiting for to
turn the
the election it didn't happen joe
biden's win has been confirmed and
that's a very good thing
okay let me just briefly mention this
because it is this is a really big story
donald trump has turned on his own vice
president donald trump has denounced his
own vice president mike pence
and there are reports coming from from
the white house
that uh donald trump is absolutely
furious with mike pence i'm not aware
and i looked spent some time today
looking in a very crazy crazy day i did
want to research this to some degree
i've not been able to find another
instance of a president turning on a
vice president to this degree in
american history
donald trump yesterday again in a tweet
that ultimately was removed by twitter
because it was making false claims
donald trump turning on his own vice
president saying quote
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done
to protect our country and our
institution giving states a chance to
certify a corrected set of facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked
to previously certify usa demands the
truth
uh i have never seen anything like this
and i
found nothing like this in the
historical record the president of the
united states
turning on his vice president now we'll
talk later about this
this was very good news for many
republicans as i've been telling you
many republicans are looking for an
escape pod
i'm not defending republicans in any way
but i recognize that some of them
feel like how do i break from trump
how do i br i need something to open the
door
to break from trump trump denouncing
pence
is exactly that where now the writing is
on the wall
trump is going to basically shrink away
for the last two weeks of his presidency
pence by being denounced by trump now is
the person that
no quote normal republicans can side
with
and many of them taking that opportunity
seeing a number of different trump
staffers
come out and say uh we agree with mike
pence we've seen some resignations there
are theories that more resignations are
coming so
i am not every single one of these
republicans is disgusting because they
should have had the testicular fortitude
or the ovarian fortitude to um uh uh
step away and denounce it four years ago
they didn't but this is they've opened
the escape hatch as trump has denounced
pence
and these are truly truly historic days
so
we'll continue covering all of these
stories we have much more today
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called steady md
they're one of our sponsors you take a
quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs they have a special
offer only for my audience you'll get
50 off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's continue we have so much
to discuss and so much to cover uh there
is
very very notable breaking news
uh that there are cabinet members
actually
discussing invoking the 25th amendment
to remove donald trump from office now
the fact that they're considering it
is the story i don't believe it will
happen
i think ultimately it's going to be a
lot of well if i supported it would you
supported it
if the two of us did what about you will
would pence go for it but the 25th
amendment
i don't believe ultimately will be
invoked but it is being discussed
cnn reporting that there are cabinet
members holding preliminary discussions
about invoking the 25th amendment to
force
donald trump to leave office early
and it is unclear whether there will be
enough cabinet members in favor
to result in donald trump's removal but
this has now been widely reported by cnn
the hill and numerous other outlets it
is abundantly clear that the
conversation
is happening in light of the violent
riots that were fomented yesterday
by donald trump house judiciary
democrats have also written a letter to
mike pence
asking him to invoke the 25th amendment
although
i i don't believe there's if it happens
or if it's being seriously considered
it's not because democrats are asking
for it
but congressman david cicilline did
write a
letter in which he says dear vice
president pence it is with great sadness
that we write to you following the
incidents
that unfolded where he goes on to say
section 4 of the 25th amendment to the
constitution
provides the vice president and majority
of sitting cabinet secretaries
with the authority to determine a
president as unfit
if they are unable to discharge the
powers and duties of
the office going on to say for the sake
of democracy we emphatically urge you to
invoke
the 25th amendment and begin the process
of removing
president trump from power obviously
donald trump should be removed from
power obviously
donald trump should have already been
impeached the georgia phone call was an
impeachable offense there have been
other impeachable offenses we could go
back to talk about saudi arabia and
yemen i mean it's
we're going back quite a way when we are
now just 13 days from the end
one way or another um i don't believe
that this will happen and i think it's
also important to say one
one other thing about this we'll be
talking a little bit later
about uh republicans now who are bailing
on donald trump
um they're they're done in 13 days
the idea that now they are being uh
brave and defiant and moral
and upstanding guys there's 13 days left
if you want to point to anyone i mean
listen
um john mccain from the beginning
was i'm not a big mccain guy but from
the beginning mccain
said what he believed he didn't wait
until there was no political
risk mitt romney his opposition to trump
is quite
milk toast but it's been consistent
after he had that weird frog leg lunch
with with trump where it seemed like
maybe he could be trump's secretary
of state but it's been years that at
least mitt romney has been consistent
and it's not like a big deal
he's mildly critical of donald trump in
most cases with a few
more serious critiques but he was
exposed to the downsides of doing it for
years
these people now who in the middle of
the night last night when everybody had
already
mostly tuned out uh came and said you
know listen our rule
our role here is just to count and
that's what we have to do there's
nothing else we can do or
some of the resignations that are taking
place now including like from mick
mulvaney who who even remembered that
mulvaney was still even
working for the trump white house that
this is it's too little too late
and we can't now put them back on the
good boys list
as a result of them doing this that's
very important to keep in mind
again the the big story is the mere fact
that the use of the 25th amendment is
being considered is
absolutely insane it should be used
there are mental health professionals
like dr bandy lee who we've interviewed
who are now asking for
a 72-hour psych hold for donald trump
most of this stuff is merely symbolic
but the fact that it's taking place
really uh confirms the dystopian reality
in which we
are living and then also importantly and
we'll talk about this next
donald trump has agreed to leave office
and i know it sounds like wait how
is that news but given the circumstances
it is
so uh late last night early this morning
as the violent trumpist rioters were
unable to stop the counting of the
electoral votes
in favor of joe biden being the next
president of the united states
donald trump through dan scavino
put out a statement that he is
agreeing to leave office on january 20th
now the the sick irony is
when he lost in early november he was
leaving
office on january 20th and so i i have
kind of mixed feelings and mixed
reactions to this
he finally is agreeing and yet it's
irrelevant because he wasn't going to be
president anymore come noon
eastern time on january 20th and even in
his statement a
quote agreeing to leave office donald
trump still repeats the exact
same uh inciting statements that
led to the violent trumpist mob rioters
yesterday in washington d.c
donald trump saying wow even though i
totally disagree with the outcome of the
election
and the facts bear me out that's a lie
nevertheless there will be an orderly
transition on january
20th while this represents the end of
the greatest first term in presidential
history
it's only the beginning of our fight to
make america great again
imagine the delusion imagine the
delusion donald trump
lost the house for republicans on 2018
in 2018
lost the senate for republicans in 2020
and was made a one-term president amidst
the most cartoonishly farcical
presidency we have ever seen we've never
seen an
actual uh a more authoritarian president
in the united states
the modern era of politics was not even
prepared we learned for something this
absurd as
even many of the checks and balances
were impotent
in actually holding trump accountable
for for his ignoring those checks and
balances
and trump says this was the best first
term of any president in history so it's
delusional
but the idea that only because trump has
agreed
this is going to be what takes place is
also just a
a laughing stock and making the united
states a laughingstock
trump was leaving one way or the other
and the fact that it is so
newsworthy that he has now come out and
said i am agreeing to an orderly
transition of power is wild
but then what's the most important thing
the most important thing is that it's
too late
it it's already not an orderly
transition of power
and the fact that trump will fly off to
who knows where
on january 19th or january 20th and
golf and tweet if he's still even
allowed on twitter which is another
story for later today
it's it's already not an orderly
transition and i think that's what we
have to understand you know
as i said as we see some republicans now
back away from
trump they need to be held accountable
for the four years that they defended
him and in the same way that donald
trump is now backing away from
resisting leaving office and saying it
will be an orderly transition
the orderly has has uh that ship has
sailed
uh thousands of violent trumpists
stormed the capital yesterday breaking
in and doing all sorts of damage and
even leading to the death of one woman
the ship has sailed on orderly and we
can't now
allow trump to revise the story
by saying i'm going to leave in an
orderly fashion on january 20th
that ship has sailed and we will talk a
little bit later about what the next
several months
might look like let's take a quick break
make sure you're following the show on
instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram
david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's uh let's continue um i
already told you
about some of the absolutely seditious
elements
and insightful elements and by that i
mean inci
not insight like oh what great insight
you have um
that donald trump posted to social media
yesterday
which were quite rapidly removed uh by
twitter
as well as facebook and that includes a
video in which donald trump says to his
uh violent riot supporters go home
we love you you're great it was stolen
uh obviously this was what was going to
happen
implying that the violence was actually
justified but it's time to go home
um twitter and facebook suspended
donald trump for an interim period as a
result of the things that he posted
donald trump was suspended from twitter
and facebook
for uh his tweets and videos to
supporters who were violently storming
the u.s capitol
trump posted the social media message
saying he he loves them and that they're
just the best people
but that it's time to go home he
repeated false claims about election
fraud
in those messages and twitter said that
it removed
three tweets for so-called severe
violations of their civic integrity
policy now
earlier in the show we already went
through what these three items were
the first was a tweet in which donald
trump denounced his own vice president
mike pence
that by itself is historic and
outrageous in nature
and in so doing he included uh
in that tweet that there was all sorts
of fraud and pence isn't doing the right
thing that tweet was initially removed
by twitter
later in the day donald as the violence
grew on the capitol
at the capitol uh donald trump posted a
one-minute video
saying it was stolen we won in a
landslide
but it's time to go home that video was
removed by twitter
and then later donald trump posted
another tweet in which he
essentially said and here i'm
paraphrasing we read the exact tweet
earlier
this is what you get when you steal the
election that we won in a landslide
twitter also removing that
and then before we knew it donald trump
had been suspended for 12 hours
on twitter and twitter also saying that
trump's account will remain locked
indefinitely if those tweets are not
removed
also indicating that future violations
of the twitter rules by donald trump
will result in the permanent suspension
of this account so
there is a micro story here and there is
a macro story here
the micro story is we've been wondering
after january 20th comes
and donald trump no longer has what are
called public public servant
i believe it's called public servant
protection by twitter
is he going to get banned very quickly
and
the reason that it's a micro story is
that it really depends on for example
does trump even continue to tweet
a lot of people email me they say david
once trump is no longer president all
he's going to be doing is tweeting
he's going to tweet even more he's going
to need twitter as the bully pulpit
because he's not going to have the bully
pulpit of the presidency
others believe that donald trump is
being so
um i don't know what the right word is
disheartened it disheartened almost
sounds like the guy has normal emotions
but
that donald trump is going to basically
end up so defeated and shrunken by
everything that's taken place in the
last few months
that we're just never going to hear from
him again once he is no longer president
so
listen twitter is making it very clear
that if trump continues
this stuff when he's no longer president
he's getting banned from twitter
altogether he has about 80 something
million followers
and uh twitter saying we we will ban him
and okay that's that's interesting
the bigger story here is that
we have seen such a debasement
and coarsening of what is acceptable to
hear from our elected officials
that it has trickled down dramatically
and now
things that four years ago would have
been inconceivable from elected
officials
are considered sort of normal because
they're not as crazy as what donald
trump is doing and i'll explain what i
mean by that
donald trump is at the very peak
of this completely unhinged uh
uh uh unbecoming language and behavior
that we would expect to see from an
american president doing everything from
inciting violent riots attacking
everything from
reporters to his own vice president i
won't give you the list because it would
take me hours to give you the list
that is a new high-water mark or
low bar call it what you want but in the
shadow
of what donald trump has made normal oh
to some degree over the last four years
or at least
expected because he continues to do it a
whole bunch of republicans
who in the past even through political
disagreements would have said
this is too much they now participate in
either
tacitly defending or repeating and sound
and and signal boosting
to some degree much of what donald trump
has been saying
and it we really saw it come to a head
yesterday
where only when these riots
led to our elected officials needing to
put on gas masks
to be evacuated from the house and
senate chambers only
then did some of them some of them mind
you
say you know what the six two-hour
objections about so-called voter fraud
that aren't going anywhere
we're get we're gonna drop it uh we we
have to come together the violence has
to stop
and and and so they also
compared to the 2015 standard have
completely debased themselves
but in the shadow of trump's more
cartoonish debasement
a lot of them are getting a pass and
you're starting to see now and we'll
have some clips of this a little bit
later
you're starting to see so-called
reasonable republicans
start to put a dividing line in the sand
saying
the trump stuff is over the line but
what josh hawley has been saying and
doing is fine
what ted cruz has been saying and doing
is fine
and this goes back to something i talked
to you about in
really in november of 2016 where i said
it is going to be a fight to prevent
hyper normalization for the next four
years
we are as humans we are so adaptable
that crazy situations become normal and
they start to feel normal to some degree
and um you know to those of us who have
been wearing masks now in public for
many many months
it's it starts to almost feel weird not
to have the mask and this is because
humans by our nature are very flexible
and adaptable we need to make sure
that the ted cruz's and the josh
hawley's
by being five percent less nuts
than trump don't sort of get
a pass in any way and with you and with
me
they they aren't getting that past but
there are lots of more
centrist types and folks who more
casually pay attention to politics we're
sort of like
yeah yeah yeah trump's over the line but
the republican party otherwise is fine
no no no the republican party and
right-wing media
have been off the wall insane for
four years at this point and we have to
remember we have to remember
not to forget that as we get beyond
donald trump
now you might find this interesting i i
was wondering
um how is right-wing media going to spin
the violent riotous insurrection that
took place in washington dc yesterday
uh will they say it was actually antifa
and black lives matter
the answer is yes some of them did and
i'll have clips of that for you a little
bit later
how are they going to frame what is a
rift
to some degree between trump and much of
the rest of the republican party for
example i put the tweet up on the screen
for you earlier
which has since been removed by twitter
of donald trump denouncing his own vice
president
mike pence where he said mike pence
failed us and
and i am not aware and was not able to
find in the historical record for the
last 150 years
a president denouncing his own vice
president
in this way i i just wasn't able to find
it how would right-wing media deal with
that
i have one example for you and it is
uh it's almost poetically just
that it comes from fox and friends host
ainsley earhart who has been
one of the most sycophantic and vile
brown nosers
of this president for four years i hope
you're sitting down for this
ainsley earhart's framing was
i hope donald trump can
forgive mike pence for not
trying to overthrow the election results
think about that okay donald trump
demanded that mike pence do uh the the
impossible
and the illegal and the immoral which is
somehow
stopped joe biden from being president
despite that being the will of the
people
and then denounced his own vice
president
after this uh violent insurrection
started
ainsley's idea is i really hope
trump will forgive pence take a look at
this video clip
you know what mike pence can just wave
that magic wand
it'll all be fixed i hope that doesn't
taint their relationship because they
have been such
supporters of one another and been a
good team because uh
donald trump how can it be good after
that i'm sure it won't be but i hope
that
you know i hope the president will be
able to forgive him because mike pence
is such a
stellar individual his walk with god is
amazing i mean he's
he's a good man and you know both of
them have done
a lot to help the country and i hope
that they can move forward and move past
this and just agree that there were
there were differences
i'm sure the president feels like i'm
responsible for him becoming vice
president so he should have done this
for me but the president as you've been
saying all along brian
the vice president has stood by his side
and supported him all along the way
so hopefully uh their friendship won't
end after this for
the good of the country i bet you it's
done yeah i know so
this is weaponized delusion
and we're going to have i couldn't
possibly get all of these clips for you
now
the this is this is one type of reaction
which is a complete
reframing it's like the equivalent of a
lot of it's a trapeze artist
flipping around and turning everything
upside down and swinging wildly
from one place to another some other
networks and some other channels and
outlets were sort of pretending none of
this was going on
even fox news at one point yesterday
five hours into the riot essentia
insurrection if you went to the fox news
website
all that all it said was uh protesters
delay counting of electoral votes which
if you had been paying attention does
not exactly capture the violence
and and seditious nature of what was
going on yesterday
others uh for example newsmax and oan
for much of the day
were just talking about completely
different things altogether it was like
nothing is going on
at one point last night in fact when the
electoral vote count continued
uh most cable networks were covering it
but if you turn to fox news it was laura
ingraham
ranting about how maybe it was actually
antifa
who did this in washington dc and i'll
get to those clips a little bit later so
as i said on yesterday's show different
people deal with loss
in different ways uh but what is
abundantly clear
is that there there is nothing too crazy
there is nothing that these trump
supporters can do
that won't find some defense in some
right-wing media
and there is no absurdity too absurd
that someone on fox news won't be able
to come
up with some kind of pretzel uh logic
pretzel i hope
trump forgives pence pence is disgusting
but at least pence immediately denounced
the violence
full stop reportedly is the guy who
actually called the national guard
to get to dc even though donald trump
was resisting doing it
and immediately came back and said
let's continue we're not going to be
delayed from doing this
pence is horrible his failures on
coronavirus his religious nuttery i mean
he's
he's horrible but the idea that trump
needs to forgive
pence uh if this is any indication of
what fox news is going to look like for
the next two or four years
we are really in for it and after the
break we we will get to yes
the idea that what could it have been
antifa that actually did the
pro-trump insurrectionist mob yesterday
we'll get to that a little bit later
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
you know one of the um traps that
i will sometimes fall into and i know
that that many of my friends do as well
and
people i follow on twitter is this idea
that okay
this is over the line no one is actually
going to find a way to defend
this and every single time
we are disappointed or is it surprised
or
let down or whatever the case may be and
this applies to the insurrectionist mob
of rioters that donald trump incited
yesterday
who went to the u.s capitol breached
security breached the doors
broke windows got into nancy pelosi's
office and vandalized and so on and so
forth
and i i sort of jokingly what's a joke
these days
i sort of uh tongue-in-cheek suggested
i'm sure they'll figure out a way to
blame antifun black lives matter for
this
and that's exactly what many people did
uh here is a clip from um
so this is happening at the high level
and it's happening at the low level
for a clip at the high level when last
night
the vote resumed uh in the joint session
um most networks were covering it
but on fox news laura ingraham
was saying uh that she
heard that uh from the washington times
there were at least
two antifa spotted in the crowd i'm not
kidding take a look
actions we saw today do not represent
this movement
the washington times is reporting that
at least two
and tifa were spotted in the crowd so
listen
first of all uh even if it were true
that there were two antifa spotted there
were
thousands of violent trump
insurrectionists pushing their way
onto the capital portico and some of
them into the building
etc etc so even if it were true that two
antifa were spotted it wouldn't really
tell us much
about the reality of what took place
yesterday it was a incited by trump
pro-trump trumpist riotous
seditious insurrection period but
what does it mean to antifa were spotted
did they have signs
because if they were just dressed in
black a lot of the riotous pro-trump
seditionists were also dressed in black
and they specifically many of them
planned to dress in black so
what if this is true it's irrelevant
whether it's true is a real question and
then of course
the idea that this is anything other
than a genuine pro-trump movement is not
supported by fact now unfortunately
so ingram is an example of this
happening at the high level oh it's two
antifa were spotted
absolute trash okay but friends of mine
who
have conservative family members as an
example
i had an inbox full of screenshots
and and uh posts yesterday of
my friend's aunt my friend's cousin
whoever else
posting all sorts of content
claiming that this entire thing was
staged by the left there really weren't
any trumpets that the trumpets that were
there and peacefully walked to the
capitol
weren't the same ones that breached and
uh of course you have to suspend all
disbelief in order to to even plausibly
consider that this is the case
but unfortunately once again when we
assume
wrongly this is over the line nobody
will defend this
even for them this is too much we're
wrong every single time and they figured
out a way
uh through a combination of arguing that
a few bad apples
maybe not even right wingers they might
the bad apples might all have been
antifa or black lives matter for which
there is no evidence
another version that i saw and in fact
there are some enlightened centrists who
have youtube channels who were making
this case
the problem is the media with bloodlust
showing the video of what's going on i
actually heard that yesterday and saw it
on twitter today which is
the the problem is not the first order
which is that people are doing this
and they are trumpists and even though
we were told it's the left that's
violent it's the right that has done
something that hasn't happened since the
19th century breaching the capital
uh building with with property crime and
vandalism and violence and all this
stuff
that's really the issue there were
people saying the the media's coverage
of this
is uh sensational and salacious
the what what that's that's what you
think is the problem the fact that media
were
accurately reporting about the seditious
insurrectionist riotous behavior that
was taking place
so we've seen every combination there is
no defense too absurd
there is no defense too ridiculous that
some of them won't try it
you know there's all these rules god
wins law which i think is
the longer an internet discussion goes
on the more likely it becomes someone
makes an analogy to hitler or nazis or
you know all the occam's razor there
should be some principle named uh
for the idea that any defense
of trump or trumpists no matter how
absurd
will eventually be made and put out
there
uh by by some of these trumpists and
all we can really do is continue
to stick to the facts uh not become
overly
you know one of the things was a lot of
people were writing to me saying how do
i respond to this you know my aunt is
posting
that what's going on is not really
what's going on what what do i do and my
my advice is do nothing
unfortunately my i i think that if you
want to adopt what i call a retail
strategy which is arguing with people
one-on-one
i don't really have advice for you i i
really don't be i don't think it's a
good idea
if some if somebody really sees what
happened yesterday and actually
believes or has convinced themselves
that they believe it was really antifa
or something like that
i don't see the point of arguing with
them i think the the healthier approach
is to say
um this person believes this stuff as a
result of like a 40-year campaign
of pseudo and anti-intellectualism and
and false
talking points that really go back to
like reagan's idea of this welfare queen
who was just getting rich off of having
kids and drove a cadillac
and and lived this great life that is
sort of the beginning of
everything we've seen immigrants are the
are dangerous and
communists are coming in and social joe
biden's association you know all that
stuff
we need to be thinking about about more
of a wholesale strategy which uh
includes changing the media landscape
changing the culture
changing education and i my instinct is
that's healthier than getting frustrated
with aunt blanche uh sharing that crazy
thing about how it was really antifa who
did the thing it to me it seems like an
exercise in in futility
uh but i'm open to having my mind change
that that's just my advice
so we we now have a situation and we're
going to have time to have a
sort of bigger conversation about this
as we get closer and closer to joe
biden's inauguration
but we have a a situation here
where donald trump now has cost the
republican party
everything trump has cost the republican
party
everything he could have cost them
donald trump cost the republican party
the house
in the 2018 midterms donald trump cost
the republican party the senate in the
2020 election
donald trump caused himself to be a
one-term
president now putting the republican
party
out of the oval office just uh 13 days
from now donald trump has cost the
republican party
global shame and embarrassment and has
ruined the careers of many many people
and so we're seeing republicans start to
turn on donald trump
donald trump denounced his own vice
president mike pence yesterday in the
middle of the capitol hill riots that he
incited himself
we saw mick mulvaney who i i learned
during the break
um went from being trump's chief of
staff to like an envoy to i think
ireland
um and and he resigned and there are
thoughts that there may be more
resignations there are thoughts that
uh there are reports that some cabinet
members are thinking about invoking the
25th amendment to try to remove donald
trump
so from the point of view of blame and
from the point of view of holding people
accountable
none of these republi oh sorry i hit my
mic i'm so excited none of these
republicans deserve
to now be praised and to be given a
blank slate because
with 13 days to go they said this is too
much for me
this segment is not about praising
the moral republicans who after three
years
and eleven and a half months are now
saying
this is too much for me this is not
about that but this
is about what does the future of the
republican party
look like and in particular after this
week not only did donald trump incite
a seditious riot in the capital but he
uh also oversaw the two people he
endorsed kelly lefler
and david perdue lose their senate seats
as incumbent republicans
to democratic challengers raphael
warnock and john ossoff
you are starting to see republicans uh
bail and
you start to see these reports like we
saw in the week
about republicans privately furious at
trump over what happened in georgia
and republicans privately furious that
trump put them in a position to have to
either
support bogus claims of voter fraud or
have to
denounce donald trump essentially and
risk being on the receiving end of
trump's anger
these republicans are complete fools and
they deserve none of our pity whatsoever
but the question does become what
happens
in the next two years and in the next
four years and what i care about is is
there an opportunity for joe biden to
get things done
because donald trump has so debased and
destroyed the republican party the
republican party will rebuild
and they may even do well in 2022.
i think it's more likely they do well in
the house than the senate because of the
the
uh cohort of senate elections that are
taking place in 2022
but the point is i care about progress
and joe biden is going to come in in 13
days and he'll start doing things that
he can do via executive order and that's
going to be fine
and then we don't know if joe biden is
going to get any supreme court picks but
if he does we'll deal with that one when
it comes to it
but the real question is going to be
from the big legislative agenda
from the big policy agenda what can joe
biden get done
we've said before these republicans are
going to be
the uh total obstructionists that we've
seen them be
in the past they are going to get in the
way of joe biden doing almost anything
with control of the senate now 50 50
with kamala harris as the tie-breaking
vote and continued control of the house
with total
government control by democrats there is
now a real possibility that some of the
big agenda items can be done can we do
a big infrastructure green energy
deal can we get the public option done
and reduce the medicare age and make the
other changes that that
joe biden has lobbied for or campaigned
on
what is joe biden going to be able to do
in terms of foreign policy and foreign
relations and rebuilding
and the questions around policy are the
same ones
but with much of the republican party
now distancing from trump the question
is is there anything that can be done
that will get a few republicans to be
allies
even if just for the next two years um
that give joe biden the opportunity to
really get some important things done
there are moral questions we could have
a ethical debate about whether
you know wouldn't that of risk
rehabilitating the
reputation of some of these republicans
who don't deserve that reputation to be
real
okay we can have that debate but at the
end of the day
trump had this list of things he was
going to do and he failed to do most of
them and that's great he was going to
you know do
his horrible health care plan he failed
he was going to build a wall and he
failed
a lot of the good things he promised he
also failed on 100 million vaccines by
the end of 2020
israeli-palestinian peace you know the
list of things that it would have been
nice to do
that he failed on is also there and
that's what it is the presidency is
ending
what can joe biden get done and is there
any politically strategic way
that these last two weeks during which
trump denounces his own vp
and republicans start to distance these
are still terrible people
but from the totally pragmatic
perspective
can this be leveraged in any way to get
something done that we really need to
get done in this country
we'll leave that question there and
we'll pick it up next week and certainly
uh when when joe biden is ultimately
sworn in we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
i received many voicemails and questions
that are very similar to this
asking whether the riot may not be a
pretext for trump to declare
martial law okay let's take a listen
uh okay the problem is that uh
i'm just watching the
trump people attacking the
congress and then
it seems like that the left
is playing into their hand
by actually making the big deal
because then it would give the trump
people
the chance to call for a
martial law yeah so this was brought up
a lot during my live streams yesterday
trump incites a riot sends in the
national guard
things are cra or doesn't as he it seems
he refused to but mike pence did but in
any case
uses the riots to say we need to declare
martial law and i'm going to stay in
office
i don't think trump is that organized
and what we've seen in the last
12 hours not in the last 24 but in the
last 12 is that donald trump has finally
put out a statement saying he's going to
leave peacefully
on january 20th it's too late for it to
be peaceful but at least he's saying
on the 20th he will be peaceful we have
seen the riots largely quelled
and uh it is not what is going to take
place
now i did also receive messages from
people saying should the left really be
saying we need more of a law enforcement
present presence on the capitol when law
enforcement
is is often the problem uh no yeah a law
enforcement president
was needed on the capitol yesterday
there's just no where
how do you quell what was going on
without a law enforcement presence and i
think that the
relatively few leftists who were saying
that um uh were
were simply were simply maybe just uh
not thinking about it uh in in the right
way but
i don't blame you for wondering would
trump incite a riot
to then create the pretext in which he
would declare martial law i think
morally he would have no problem with it
i think the limitations are he's not
that organized and he's already said i'm
leaving and the riots have calmed down
now there are rumors that there are
going to be more riots today and even in
the
the days leading up to january 20th we
will pay attention to that and we will
cover it uh if
if it should come to pass we will be
discussing on the bonus show today
um there have been some videos which
purport to be
police actually removing barricades to
let protesters
rioters in yesterday to the u.s capitol
we're going to talk about that because
there are a number of perspectives about
those supposed videos
we will also talk about in the midst of
this joe biden is actually getting some
sweet revenge
in that merrick garland will be his
attorney general merrick garland
barack obama's supreme court nominee who
was obstructed
by mitch mcconnell and republicans back
in 2016.
and much more on today's bonus show i i
very quickly i so appreciate the couple
hundred people that grabbed memberships
over the last 48 hours
um in appreciation of the the coverage
we've been doing i really appreciate
it i invite you to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with
no other fees or copays visit
steadymd.com
pacman to get started